[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle max mollon je suis
géologue
bienvenue à la soirée de sensibilisation
aux conséquences du dérèglement
climatique alors ses conséquences
quelles sont-elles pour clermont ferrand
puis torrentielles et les glissements de
terrain espèces végétales invasives
canicule migrants due aux déplacements
climatique
ces choses là nous les connaissons nous
allons plutôt nous concentrer sur le cas
d'école de lyon en janvier de l'année
dernière
ces images d'archivés montre ce que l'on
a pu éviter même si depuis le rhône est
contenu par des digues anti crue voici
l'implantation du cours d'eau du rhône
ce qui est remarquable c'est les
conséquences du yo-yo climatique sur ces
fleuves le yoyo climatique qu'est ce que
c'est par exemple ici dans les semaine
dernière nous avons eu un temps
extrêmement clément le week-end dernier
faisait 6 degrés à lyon et sûrement ici
également tandis que météo france
annonce 25 degrés lundi prochain tandis
qu'il pleut ici
il neige dans les montagnes quand il se
met à faire chaud la neige fond et vient
gorges et le rhône le rhône rentrer en
crue c'est la brutalité de ce changement
dans un très petit temps que l'on
appelle le dérèglement climatique
qui donc n'est pas un réchauffement
climatique même s'il ya un réchauffement
des températures comme vous l'avez
sûrement suivi à l'époque dès janvier
l'année dernière la violence de cette
crue est exceptionnelle et a surpris
tout le monde
elle a surpris en particulier sur ce
point la centrale nucléaire du bugey en
amont de lyon
la crue est devenue une inondation à cet
endroit là endommagé la centrale et la
préfète avait 24 heures pour réagir
un désastre écologique sans précédent on
voit ici la zone inondable en rose
sachant que la raffinerie de feyzin qui
se trouve en dessous signifiée par le
triangle a connu d'ailleurs une
explosion deux ans après son ouverture
en 1966 et toute cette zone est la
vallée en dessous répu être victime du
coût des produits chimiques et
radioactifs
arie par parra 7 parce rhône déchaînés
et donc la préfète a décidé en suivant
les recommandations des expertes
d'ouvrir la digue à deux points pour
inonder vaulx en velin plutôt qu'ils
n'ont de toute la vallée et par ce lourd
sacrifice permet d'éviter une
catastrophe écologique sans précédent
la question ici c'est comment on se
relève de cette crise après on va
assister à un fragment d'émissions radio
qui date de six mois plus tard afin
d'être très concentré je vous invite à
tous fermé les yeux
s'il vous plaît faites moi confiance ça
nous permettra d'être très concentré sur
l'émission de radio qui va vous raconter
ce qui s'est passé six mois plus tard
nancy
formation à lyon six mois après la
catastrophe
l'heure de faire les comptes pour la
région auvergne rhône-alpes un bilan en
demi teinte
puis l'antenne le siegfried wolf qui va
juillet 2048 vaulx en velin le triste
paysage offert par l'inondation du 25
janvier dernier commence à peine à
évoluer voiture sur le dos devant tueur
de pharmacie éventrée par un tronc
échoué et une zone baignée de traces
toxiques situation de crise
pas pour tous yop holding ravi serial
entrepreneuse et conseillère en
résilience écologique pour la région
voient cela comme une opportunité plutôt
que de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
l'opening rabhi prend le pari de vivre
avec
mieux que ça elle en a fait son gagne
pain en lançant il ya six mois sa
compagnie de voyages solidaires
elle sort sur la mode du tourisme
écologique elle propose de passer ses
vacances d'été en prêtant main forte aux
lyonnais pour renforcer les rangs de
l'action de nettoyage solidaire
l'entrepreneuse n'en est pas à son
premier coup d'essai notamment dans
l'accompagnement à la transition
économique changement d'activité des
stations de ski du au yoyo climatique en
pleine saison
mutations de la cuisine des bouchons
lyonnais s'adaptant aux nouvelles
denrées venues du sud
ce qu'elle appelle le nez au local moi
vous savez les touristes ce qu'ils
aiment c'est redécouvrir la france à la
fin du séjour
on leur réserve différentes visites à
thème alors déjà le safari ont désormais
une photographier les animaux venant du
grand parc miribel jonage qui ont envahi
certaines rues de vaulx en velin
ensuite la culture avec le concert de
charité par des artistes locaux en
faveur de la rénovation la gastronomie
avec le nouveau campus qui revisite la
cuisine méridionale à la lyonnaise et
enfin la détente
on les remonte dans les halles auprès de
nos partenaires en station de ski
thermale on exploite l'eau de fonte des
neiges et ont rempli les bas en demi
teinte de cette success story
le malaise demeure dans la région
alors que certains portent encore de
lourdes pertes la réduction d'impôt
proposé aux autres de personnes
sinistrées ne suffit pas en effet
certains habitants peinent encore à
trouver un logement stable et malgré les
pieds au sec
les assurances ont encore le jusqu'au
cou
ce que vous venez de vivre à l'instant
était une fiction
vous l'avez deviné cette fiction été
construite en collaboration avec des
experts géologues urbanistes de l'école
urbaine de lyon j'ai construit cette
fiction et on l'a utilisé pour démarrer
un débat avec les experts et les
citoyens sur les enjeux du dérèglement
climatique à l'échelle urbaine pour
débattre les enjeux tous ensemble nous
ça me concentrer sur ce personnage
léopoldine rami le personnage de l'open
rabhi ici effectivement un personnage
fictif qui n'a rien à voir avec la
famille rhabiller ou pierre rabhi
incarne de manière dérangeante
le sujet du débat le fait d'utiliser la
crise comme la poule aux oeufs d'or
elle incarne les logiques ici de
l'exploitation et du profit elle incarne
l'une des sources du problème climatique
en effet d'après les géologues du giec
la source du réchauffement c'est notre
production de co2 qui a explosé sur les
150 dernières années depuis la
révolution industrielle
on peut dire que notre système
capitaliste est construit sur une autre
fiction celle d'une croissance
économique infinie dans un monde aux
ressources limitées alors cette fiction
spéculative que vous avez vécu ce n'est
pas de la science fiction
cette manière d'aller explorer lier pour
discuter d'ici et maintenant c'est ce
qu'on appelle le design fiction
effectivement je m'appelle max mollo
mais je ne suis pas géologue
je suis futurologue spécialisée dans le
poil à gratter et designers j'anime des
débats comme je lé fais en janvier
dernier à lyon et non pas en 2048 ce que
vous venez découvrir donc c'était du
design fiction mais aujourd'hui on va
parler d'innovation et comment cette
pratique du design fiction permet de
relancer l'innovation droit dans le mur
pour nous permettre d'en parler qui a un
téléphone dans l'assistance s'il vous
plaît veuillez lever les mains merci
beaucoup
voyez des ingénieurs et des designers
ont conçu ces téléphones
avant quand
je faisais mes études de design je
pensais que l'audience était de
concevoir uniquement des objets mais
aujourd'hui dans le domaine de
l'innovation le design c'est de façonner
notre relation aux nouvelles
technologies c'est de trouver leur usage
la raison pour qu'elle vous parle
d'innovation c'est que c'était mon
domaine celui dans lequel j'ai évolué et
que face aux dérèglements climatiques et
aux grands enjeux de la société la
réponse qui revient à chaque fois ses
relances ont l'innovation ensemble je
propose de déconstruire cette expression
est d'en construire une critique
relancer l'innovation c'est une
expression qui racontre notre société à
elle toute seule elle symbolise le récit
puissant celui du progrès
un récit sur progrès qui nourrit nos
imaginaires des vaccins jusqu'aux
voitures volantes et on peut faire trois
critiques trois critiques que je
construis qu'une chercheuse qui
s'appelle tiphaine casitas ni que
souhaite remercier ici pour expliquer
ses critiques je vais partir de ce
schéma saint-germain très connu dans le
domaine depuis 15 ans et je vous renvoie
vers les travaux de julian bleecker who
do you done and will be des anglais vous
intéresser au sujet du design fiction ce
diagramme canton le déploie on voit que
sur l'axé du présent sur notre
représentation linéaire du présent vers
le futur on a la vaste quantité des
futurs possibles en tout cas du plus
probable au moins probable en
prospective on aurait tendance à prédire
et essayer de prédire ce futur ou à
essayer de faire prendre un virage à la
société ici on va essayer de questionner
dans cet espace des possibles où se
trouve le préférable et donc pour
revenir cette phrase relance en
innovation premières critiques qu'on va
qu'on va développer c'est que les
technologies ont des conséquences
insoupçonnées qui se passe après cette
situation préférable qu'on imagine
prenons comme en prenant un premier
exemple les technologies de séquençage
de l'adn qui permettent dans le domaine
de la santé de savoir donc ce gros frigo
là c'est quelque chose qui séquence
votre adn avec un cheveu une goutte de
sang pour préférablement qui permet de
connaître
vos sensibilités en termes de santé en
fonction de votre alimentation ou les
produits chimiques auxquels vous êtes
vous êtes confrontés quels types de
problèmes de santé vous pourriez
développer par rapport à votre propre
patrimoine génétique
quand on couple ça aux algorithmes de
prédiction dans la domaine de la santé
on en vient à pouvoir modifier un tout
petit peu le genre d'interface que l'on
trouve canton par exemple on essaye
d'enregistrer nos compétences et nos
performances dans le domaine du footing
de la course ou du sport est ici pour
essayer de préciser quel serait votre
espérance de vie
ce scénario très probable pose un
problème qui serait par exemple le fait
qu'une assurance vous proposera une
prime pour pouvoir avoir accès à vos
tickets de caisse
voire tout simplement être un capteur
dans vos toilettes et ce projet a été
construit en collaboration avec des
chercheurs de l'inra l'institut national
de recherche en agronomie et le but
était de leur montrer ses scénarios pour
les confronter aux futurs de leurs
propres recherches
ensuite j'ai design est une autre étape
en travaillant non plus avec l'inra mais
avec l'espace éthique ile de france qui
est une commission éthique à l'hôpital
saint louis à paris et sur le même sujet
on s'est questionné plutôt sur l'angle
des angles sociaux là par exemple on a
imaginé que si le système de santé était
construit différemment ce système de
santé qui prend cette direction il
n'irait plus chez le médecin avec un
symptôme recevrez un email qui nous
dirait en fonction du capteur qu'on a
dans vos toilettes on sait qu attention
vous allez développer une maladie grave
et ici aussi on a imaginé que le groupe
des malades génétique anonyme avait créé
leur propre application pour s'échanger
des petites annonces et par exemple ici
sept personnes profitent de la soirée
est très nalinnes et artifices avant le
grand soir
donc est ce qu'il faut retenir que le
design fiction ici permet de révéler des
conséquences éthiques qui sont après la
zone du préférable que les ingénieurs ou
que moi en tant que designer j'aurais
j'aurais imaginé et d'aller chercher en
dehors de cette zone là est la raison
pour laquelle on appelle ça du design
finalement c'est qu'on s'intéresse
vraiment aux usages de
mains dans ce cas-là aux usages et aux
objets khimki pas pleurer ce monde
fictionnel
deuxième critique deuxième critique
c'est se poser la question sur quoi
s'appuie le progrès pourra devenir sous
finalement cet espace des possibles des
futurs de l'innovation sous le tapis il
se passe quelque chose d'invisible qui
est l'exploitation des ressources qui
sont elles limitées
un des exemples du mythe de l'innovation
serait la révolution du tout électrique
en 2018 la france se positionne numéro
un des champs d'éoliennes offshore comme
celui ci même si celui là est à 1000
dahlgren qui est un des trois entre le
danemark et la suède pour fabriquer ce
genre de composants qui viennent stocker
l'énergie il y en a dans tous nos
téléphones il a dans les led dans les
ordinateurs portables les panneaux
photovoltaïques et les éoliennes et les
batteries de voitures électriques
il faut mines et des terres rares
aujourd'hui le premier exploitant de
terres rares au monde qui à plus de 90%
de parts du marché c'est la chine est
trouvé deux tiers de leur production
vient d'un endroit en mongolie
intérieure dans une baie où tout est
cette mine là quand on zoome un petit
peu vous pouvez le faire vous même sur
google vous allez voir cette zone sur le
côté cette zone ce côté c'est la honte
où les déchets viennent s'accumuler et
ses déchets contiennent des matériaux
radioactifs de l'uranium ici qui sont 32
fois supérieur à la concentration
normale sachant que tchernobyl était à
14 fois du coup la chine va être face à
un problème écologique majeure et
pourquoi la chine a un monopole tout
simplement parce que les autres pays ont
arrêté cette production cause des enjeux
de pollution et des enjeux écologiques
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
entre 90 et 97 % de parts de ce marché
dont conclusion avec notre approche
actuelle et à la vitesse à laquelle nous
consommons nos ressources
il nous faudrait une deuxième planète
terre pour arriver à continuer
d'explorer ces futurs là la troisième
critique c'est que le récit du progrès
ne s'appuie pas uniquement sur
l'exploitation de ressources qui sont
elles limitées mais aussi sur
l'exploitation de personnes qui sont
asservis
c'est quelque chose que moi
finalement je parle à mon propre titre
j'ai découvert ans alors que je design
est justement ce genre d'objet des
téléphones et je pense est généralement
l'utilisateur qui va s'en servir comment
faire pour que ça marche le mieux à la
marque au coût des matériaux et puis au
prix final mais je pensais jamais aux
personnes qui permettent à cet objet
d'exister par exemple dans nos
téléphones et dans tous les produits
électroniques du cobalt en tout cas on
doit mines et du cobalt est l'une des
des mines principal en république
démocratique du congo emploie 150 milles
ce qu'on appelle des creuseurs 150000
krauser et sur 750 mille un tiers sont
des enfants
amnesty international dénonce des
maltraitances envers ses enfants en
particulier parce qu'ils sont payés
entre 1 et 2 euros par jour mais aussi
parce qu'ils sont exposés à des
poussières toxiques qui vers
provoquerait des maladies pulmonaires
le deuxième étape c'est le montage de ce
téléphone et de ses composants on se
rappelle pour ceux qui l'avaient suivi
la crise car et apple avec ses usines en
chine foxconn où un certain nombre
d'employés s'était suicidé du fait
d'avoir douze heures de travail par jour
et d'avoir un seul jour en tout cas
période de congés par an pour aller voir
leur famille et qui étaient parfois
supprimés et enfin quand nos objets sont
en fin de vie je me suis rendu compte
que ces objets que je produisais quand
il était en fin de vie quitte avec notre
territoire à et finissait à accra par
exemple la capitale du ghana ou dans une
déchetterie à ciel ouvert 41 millions de
tonnes de déchets s'accumulent par an là
où le reste du continent africain a
cumulé 1 19 million de tonnes
la conclusion c'est qu'il vive
finalement un cauchemar pour qu'on
puisse vivre notre rêve de l'innovation
celui auquel j'ai participé en tant que
designer et si vous êtes intéressés par
la question
vous pouvez aller voir le concept
d'hannibal quijano qui parle de
colonialité ou encore le chercheur
français antonio casilli qui part de
communalité numérique parce que c'est
bien de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
comment finalement cette matrice
coloniale du pouvoir a encore effet
entre leurs effets
aujourd'hui via la production décidées
ou des objets numériques donc relancer
l'innovation comme réponse aux grands
défis écologiques s'est relancée ces
trois problèmes
le problème des conséquences éthiques
potentiel des technologies le problème
de l'exploitation des ressources et le
problème de l'exploitation des personnes
et du coup quoi faire alors je vous
donne ce que moi j'essaye de faire
personnellement et peut-être ça peut
vous inspirer j'essaie de me dire qu'est
ce qui est hors champ
même si je suis content on est de mon
point de vue occidental à cette vision
là de de ma société qui est construit
sur sur le mythe du progrès qu'est ce
qui se passe hors champ en suisse
conscient de qui travaillent pour moi
par exemple les étudiants et les
bénévoles qui organisent cette soirée
mais aussi les personnes qui font le
ménage avant et après cet événement et
qui sans elle on ne pourrait pas on ne
serait pas là ensemble de cas pas dans
ces conditions
d'ailleurs autant les remercier deuxième
point
qu'est ce que je peux arrêter par
exemple à 6 ans j'ai décidé d'arrêter
d'acheter des téléphones portables donc
je recycle ce que les autres personnes
jettent je verrai utilise alors qu'ils
sont encore en état de marche et j'ai
également arrêté le design dans le
domaine de l'innovation la place fait du
design fiction pour relancer
l'innovation droit dans le mur comme
jeudi et nous permettent d'ouvrir une
brèche de discussion qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire d'autre peut-être arrêter
d'acheter sans autre sans savoir d'où
viennent les choses ou encore une phrase
que j'aime bien qui est de dire que
parfois c'est en arrivant en haut de
l'échelon qu'on se rend compte que
l'échelle de notre carrière on l'avait
mis sur le mauvais mur alors peut-être
qu'ils vont pourrait arrêter notre
métier et en faire un autre
en tout cas la manière dont on le fait
et enfin apprendre et pour détailler ce
point là je reviens sur ce schéma pour
dire que notre récit de novation
finalement c'est un récit dominant qui
écrase les autres manières de vivre en
dehors de ceux de ce récit là en dehors
de ce triangle
c'est par exemple pour nous complètement
inconcevable dont 4 est difficile
d'imaginer comment vivre sans progrès
sans croissance
son profit est peut-être aussi sans
pollution alors que peut-être les
réponses se passe pas à l'intérieur de
ce col mais à l'extérieur et qu'il
faudrait aller chercher d'autres
présents d'autres manières de vivre
présents s'en aller explorer le futur
d'aller voir d'autres manières de vivre
ces présents qui peine à devenir de
futurs justement mais également à les
voir dans nos modes de vie passée ces
modes de vie que l'on a et 1 parce qu'il
correspondait pas à ce récit d'une
société capitaliste fondé sur le progrès
et l'innovation est souvent certains
parlent d'un mur du futur donc je
propose que si on aime face à un mur du
futur peut-être fait que l'on ne marche
pas dans la bonne direction
merci moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]